Hunter Biden we'll get to the latest
Hunter Biden scandal
a real deep Scandal of public interest
not just drugs and hookers and that kind
of stuff but something that really gets
to the corruption of his family and his
father
but first I've gone a little lighter on
Hunter Biden than a number of
conservatives have they just Hammer
every picture every crack pipe falling
out of his mouth every hooker he's video
himself with and they're making fun of
his drug addiction and I've tried not to
do that because I don't think that
people ought to be judged for the bad
stuff that they used to do especially if
they've cleaned themselves up there but
for the grace of God go all of us
everybody's done bad things all have sin
had fallen short of the glory of God so
I'm not going to make fun of him for
that I've got plenty of friends who have
been addicts and drunks and everything
so I'm not going to really hit him too
much for that
I don't think people should be judged
for the terrible things they used to do
I think that they should be judged for
the terrible things that they're doing
right now
so that they can correct those things
and Hunter Biden
currently a huge scumbag
forget about what he did on Skid Row
forget about the hookers and the drugs
and everything what this guy is doing
right now he he took his baby mama
London Roberts to court to try to reduce
the child support payments that he is
sending to his daughter Navy is this
daughter Navy that he will not
acknowledge he will not meet this poor
little girl is four years old her father
openly hates her and her grandfather is
the president of the United States and
he refuses to acknowledge her as well
and her her grandfather Joe Biden oh
good old nice guy Joe that devout
Catholic Joe Biden he puts up stockings
at the White House his his this little
girl's grandmother or step-grandmother
Dr Jill Biden oh sweet old Dr Jill who
writes children's books she refuses to
acknowledge this poor girl too girls
four years old they put up stockings at
the White House of all the Biden
grandkids except for one
and then this Dirtbag Hunter Biden goes
into court says I want to pay my baby
mama significantly less money this is a
guy who's shaking down every corrupt
oligarch around the world in Ukraine in
China from this guy is guy who's made
millions and millions of dollars tens of
millions of dollars and he won't pay
child support to or he won't pay a
serious amount of Child Support to his
baby mama and then he in court
tries to insist that his own daughter
isn't allowed to use his last name
that they've got to change the little
girl's last name or stop her from using
the Biden name he's so ashamed of this
four-year-old girl it's such scumbag
behavior and it's from Hunter Biden who
I guess we expect that from from this
idea that Hunter he's cleaned up you
know the support of a loving father that
really got him over his addiction no
he's a complete dirt bag today and he's
doing something worse today than
anything he's done in the past which is
hurt his little daughter and scandalize
her
and and this is exactly what the
millstone verse of the Bible is about
and and and Hunter's Dirtbag father Joe
Biden's doing virtually the same thing
as pres imagine you're a little girl
you're four years old you're starting to
become kind of conscious you're starting
to be aware of things and what you were
told every single day is that your
father hates you and your grandfather
the president of the United States hates
you too because you're not good enough
to be acknowledged in fact they're going
to take you to court so that you can't
use their last name which is your last
name because your
their their daughter and granddaughter
it's just so awful and Hunter doesn't
get nearly enough grief for this and Joe
Biden doesn't get enough grief for this
either
yeah Hunter engage in all sorts of
colorful awful behavior and
I guess he doesn't do that anymore who
knows maybe he still does and yeah he's
a corrupt public official or he's the
corrupt son of a public official and
seems to be the bag man for the whole
Biden family and that's really bad and
it's
kind of run-of-the-mill corruption at a
much grander scale than we've seen
before but I don't know this one gets me
a lot worse him the Biden family acting
like a a mafia family going around and
shaking down corrupt people around the
world selling American influence that's
worse as a matter of public corruption
but it bothers me less than this I just
think about that before I mean it's
because I have young kids you think
about that four-year-old girl
who who is whose father and grandfather
hate her so much that they'll take her
to court to to avoid acknowledging her
just just disgusting stuff from an
absolutely disgusting family that should
change their behavior as soon as
possible but there there is an aspect of
public corruption here too which is
that we got another Hunter Biden text so
you had that first one which was Hunter
Biden shaking down a Communist Party of
china-affiliated business
executive and saying hey send me money
I'm sitting next to my dad my dad's the
big guy over here and we're gonna hold a
grudge and we're gonna make China hurt
and we're gonna make you hurt we're the
influence of the United States if you
don't send us a payoff now and the Biden
Camp the White House is insisting that
this these were just the rantings of an
addict who was lying who was desperate
you know trying to compare Hunter Biden
to some junkie on the street who goes
and steals his grandma these VCR or
something like that you know a guy who's
just lying and making things up even
though you read the texts they're pretty
specific they seem fairly Lucid for a
guy who's smoking a bunch of crack and
in throws of addiction well now we got a
second text
asking for 10 million bucks from a CCP
linked associate
and you know if this guy just put down
all the stuff that was bad for him and
if he had just started consuming things
that were really good for him he would
have had a much better life he would
have he would have been consuming good
things like good ranchers right now head
on over to goodranchers.com he's promo
code Knowles as our great nation's
birthday approaches we are coming
together as Americans and savoring the
delicious Taste of homegrown American
made meat our friends at good Ranchers
have the best Quality Meats that you've
ever tasted and they only sell meat that
was raised here in the USA from now
until Independence Day good ranchers
will be offering the best deals to give
you freedom from the meat aisle from rib
eyes New York strips all-natural Burgers
to the most delicious chicken you could
ever want good ranchers has something
for everyone plus right now you will get
30 off with our code Knowles at
goodranchers.com if you are looking for
a way to wow your family during the 4th
of July check out their website recipe
of the Texas style chopped patty melt
I test this out because I want to make
sure that I'm not just imagining it I've
tested out good ranchers meat at dinner
parties with friends with with a number
of people they all agree it's just
absolutely top of the line the price is
shockingly low what are you waiting for
let the mouth-watering aroma of American
made meat fill the air bringing Joy
Unity intellectual flavors to your
celebrations goodranchors.com use code
nulls you get 30 bucks off any box
codenolsgoodranchors.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
so we got we got this new text here
what's the new text
this is uh days after we we get the
WhatsApp text from 2017 about Joe Biden
sitting next to him
well now in a message dated August 3rd
2017. Hunter tells uh gong when Kevin
dong CCP Affiliated business associate
that he wants to quit squabbling over
peanuts and settle on a firm deal by
putting quote this to bed tonight and
get to work I'm tired of this Kevin I
can make five million dollars in salary
in any law firm in America
and why is it because Hunter Biden is
such a genius expert at the law I don't
think so I think it's because even if
you're working in a law firm in America
he'd be peddling his father's influence
but instead he became even more corrupt
and even greedier and he tried to sell
his father's influence overseas
with the knowledge of his father by the
way Hunter writes very simple 10 million
dollars per annum budget to use to
further the interest of the JV of this
of this business interest this move to 5
million is completely new to me and is
not acceptable obviously
so he's saying you only want to pay me
five million dollars a year to sell
American influence I don't think so
Buster you got to double that he says if
you think this is about money it's not
the bidens are the best I know at doing
exactly what the chairman wants from
this partnership let's not quibble over
peanuts
five million dollars in peanuts very
expensive peanuts
but the bidens or the but not Hunter
Biden not even just Joe Biden the Biden
family
because this is not
a a new kind of behavior that cropped up
when Hunter Biden found the crack pipe
this is behavior that the Biden family
including Joe Biden's brother that
including the whole family has engaged
in for decades now and so it's not
surprising what do we take away from
this we take away
that if you think Joe Biden has not been
involved in his family's corruption I
have got a bridge in Rehoboth Beach
Delaware to sell you but
this gets to the heart of a lot of the
squabbling on the GOP side over 2024 and
relitigating 2020 which is
a family that does this a family that
sells American influence for millions
and millions of dollars brazenly openly
in WhatsApp messages Joe Biden bragging
about it at the Council of Foreign
Relations I went to Ukraine and I told
that prosecutor if you don't if you
don't fire that prosecutor I'm gonna
withhold a billion dollars in American
Aid and you stop you you fire that
prosecutor who's investigating the
company that's paying off my son a ton
of money for me to Peddle American
influence he's bragging about it he's
open about it it's all there and
transparent and you're telling me
that a family
that engages in that kind of public
corruption and a party that sanctions
that kind of public corruption wouldn't
steal an election oh yeah we just found
what 300 mail-in ballots in a in a
locker in Michigan from 2020. bet there
are a lot of lockers in Michigan but
there are a lot of lockers in
Pennsylvania and Arizona and Georgia I
bet there are a lot
you're telling me
that a party where the the two of the
three most prominent families in the
last 20 years the clintons and the
bidens the Obamas are corrupt too they
come out of Chicago machine politics but
in this case we're talking about selling
American influence top dollar engaging
in really corrupt activity and we got we
got the bidens and the Clinton is dead
to rights at least you telling me that
party wouldn't steal an election give me
a break
this is going to be the real issue for
me and I I need a GOP candidate to
explain to me not how you're going to
lock up the Border though that would be
good not how you're going to turn the
economy around
it's actually probably straightforward
enough not even how you're going to
wield government power to fix the
education system and the culture and I
want to know all that
I want to know how you're going to
overcome the Democrats rigging the
election like they did in 2020 and I
need Trump to explain that to me I need
the scientist to explain that to me we
you know we're we're in the midst of the
chrysosons the Chris Christie
Renaissance I think Chris Christie to
explain this to me in Vivek and Mike
Pence and whoever else is running okay
and you got to explain that to me
because
right now the the Democrats feel that
they've got a very solid electoral asset
in the way that they've rigged the
system what a great clip that was make
sure that you subscribe you ring that
Bell you get every episode every
interview every yes or no game we'll see
you next time